hey it's my old pal Andy Richter how are
you Andy hi come on in
I'm fine you know I'm managing just you
know pretty well but I gotta say I'm a
little lonely it's okay to talk this way
but I missed the physical contact we
always had yeah our pre-show hug
I love the pre-show hug yeah why don't
we go ahead and do it anyway yeah we
just did it but let's do it the other
day but let's do Andy OH
see you buddy how are you oh come on you
know what I really miss Andy what every
day at this time we'd feed each other
some cake why are we sure would yeah boy
would win we really really would I have
some cake here now for you do you yeah
I'll take you you're the best Andy yeah
just throw that anywhere Andy you know
after cake you got to think about your
teeth you know you're absolutely right
Andy and we had always brush each
other's teeth we sure would here go
ahead get me now how do you get me oh
that's good oh yeah watch our own teeth
I've never been able to figure this out
I don't know why we do this there really
doesn't seem to be any reason for it and
we don't use toothpaste right don't
forget the eyeballs ah yeah thanks the
nose
yea-ah any why why Andy why why not good
point
get in there oh man Andy you're the best
thank you